those joining us by the livestream this
is a meeting in an infinite series on
language completeness and consistency we
have a number of topics today
they don't look to me to be the most
exciting but we'll see how they go
really focusing on the consistency of
aspect today rather than the
completeness fair enough okay all right
so let's start off with the loud heads
right so he had this discussion last
time about aloud heads can we see some
examples of where loud heads was used
they can sense what was the issue here I
mean so this is the issue is when a loud
head is being taken from a function so
so I mean I could in principle have
something like flatten which I mean
flatten implicitly I don't know what how
does flat and deal with heads ratio
flatten only looks at lists like things
no it just did that so yeah so flatten
would also be a place where we could
possibly add this symbol right
let's take a look flatten they see
flatten has a third argument which gives
flattened sub expressions with head h
okay now we could also allow an option
for allowed heads there the question is
what is the setting for that option and
the case where it is looking at the head
of the has been presented with right
correct okay so what was the case so the
issue is so automatic will be one
possible setting but we wanted to use
that for a different purpose we wanted
to use that for list comer Association
in the case of total we wanted that to
be list comma Association so we have
right you might want slightly different
defaults for different functions of
total we want more than just lists right
okay so so we want an automatic setting
for that and the question is what do we
want to call it when it is getting the I
mean we also might want to be able to
give something where where we use a
symbol to represent the top-level symbol
as well as so for example I could
imagine something which looks like this
well which means either it's the
top-level symbol as you were given it by
the way we've got a bunch of background
noise can we try to cut the we got a you
know either it's the symbol as you were
given it or its list and I'm making
sense
that makes sense Steven go ahead but but
the question the big question is is
inherited you know the wrong thing to
use to represent the head you were given
right and I can see the argument that it
is the wrong thing because inherited is
usually something which comes from
outside rather than being a thing that
you are now being applied to mm-hmm so
this might be a little weird but what
about the labs have allowed heads goes
to head I think that's really weird
because I mean we're saying we're
listing the head
I mean that's like a function I mean if
yes we could do but I think that that's
not helping us really
yeah I guess I just write I feel that
inherited is a little bit wrong because
it's you know might be wrong and also
automatic really feels to me like
freight automatic generally means do
something sensible for this particular
input I mean we do sometimes use it as -
well we don't want to tell you exactly
what we're doing so we're just going to
call it automatic but in in our better
cases automatic means look at the input
and do something sensible yeah but I
mean your list of list Association
America Ray byte array that's not really
look at the input
that's consider the function you're in
do something reasonable for that right
which is why I write so Jose wouldn't
like that to be automatic but I'm like
that doesn't really feel automatic to me
I mean we sometimes do that but I think
that's a relatively low rating for
automatic it's relatively poor but it's
not it's not terrible and I mean the
alternative is we've got all okay who
else has an idea here I you know the
best idea I've seen is inherited even
though it is slightly wrong it's wrong
it's frustratingly wrong I mean all
means any possible head so anything
normal it will go inside of which for
total would be pretty weird unless your
lowest levels are all number cute right
because no total of sign of two heads
goes to all allowed head suppose all
would give you - yeah and flatten would
be weird as well but it's not totally
useless I mean obviously blank will be
an alternative there as well yeah for
frightened it's actually not totally
useful because the basically gives you
gives you all the arrows and the
expression
right what's the head yeah of the thing
I assume that the Gees disappear but
it's a little weird the issue head is
that's a difficult so something we also
would like in this design is we've made
an incompatible change okay to basically
so that you know total of two times pi
doesn't give you 2 plus pi anymore which
is correct but we want people to get an
easy way to get back to the old behavior
no we don't that behavior is insane okay
[Music]
I don't I don't believe total will have
documented that and and I just I think
it's consider because they did document
that which was a completely insane let's
don't go that this is that that was you
know okay the question then is by the
way Sonora live stream is asking why
allowed heads doesn't have documentation
probably because it doesn't exist yet
yeah that's what I doesn't have
documentation does have internal
documentation doesn't it it does it's
only I could open that yes okay oh look
at that list that's convenient
I don't see I mean look okay
our choices I think are quotes head
which I don't really like it's inherited
which I also don't really like I think
it's the least evil of the various
possibilities right so you know I would
submit that in in for most of the
functions right it's going to be you
know one or two things right that the
fault is going to be list or list enough
explicitly it's just not it's I mean no
I mean because it will grow and we want
to be able to make it grow
I mean another possibility that we use
in some places similar to automatic is
full I see I would not be although I
mean who would know the difference is
what I'm getting at or how do we
document that well the same way we
document the difference between full and
all and plot range based on the
description in the table
I mean maybe an alternate for automatic
would be default we can't use that that
does have a different meaning I agree
yeah it's a different meaning by the way
senator our live stream is pointing out
but then the documentation there's a
transpose allowed heads arrow or what is
transposed to with allowed heads not a
great deal so this is one of the one of
the reasons why we hadn't documented
that yet is that it was not very well
implemented for transpose which was the
original motivation for the symbol right
and also in transpose it requires that
heads at a given level all have to be
the same because otherwise we just can't
do the transpose
right but basically what Trent what it
does is allows you to treat you know
treat lists of arrays as sorry lists of
associations or as as you know erasable
elements right unlike and what happens
in in maze or whatever sorry that was a
stupid pun um okay look I think
inherited is the least evil of the
possibilities that we see in front of us
that's what I think we should go with
okay I don't like it very much but I
think it's what we should go with so
going back to that documentation
notebook the--just closes to moment ago
yes so the table has lists and
Association and is list correct I mean
you know if I that's just wrong I mean
when it says allowed lists Abbas the
Ryan structure right that's just wrong
presumably well do we want to have a do
we want to have a thing that's say quote
list representation that we just want to
go full in on name strings you know not
necessarily heads a string head yeah so
the string list would be different from
the symbol list or you're saying that
the string we wouldn't have a string
list we would have like array heads or
array or something like that
we're generalized I mean I I mean what
it means is things which upon you know I
would give a definition upon applying
normal you get a list but that would
also apply to Association and also
column for that matter I mean these are
things which you know you sort of
automatically
right these are things that the listable
functions automatically thread over
right these are their lists like yeah
they're LITTLEST representations yeah
internally we have a function called
list representation queue which gives
true for these where these guys listen I
think in this table we should take out
the lines that say listen Association we
should and we should give automatic
inherited all and then the list of heads
the head and the list of heads we should
just take out those two lines yeah
that's fine well should we have magic
strings for the lists for the list
representation I think if in the future
we need that so be it yeah I don't think
I don't think anybody's gonna be asking
for just those versus data data set or
numeric array it's okay is sorting
function so to summarize the long thread
is that you know where some of us are
uncomfortable with the name sorting
function by the way our live stream is
asking what automatic actually does no
the conclusion is automatic it takes the
reasonable list of lists and Association
like things an inherited takes the thing
from the actual function as presented
right and and exactly what list
you know what list of heads made it very
slightly may vary from function to
function of what automatic means yes but
by the way so and transpose the default
would be inherited right for loud heads
they think it should stay list is it
list right now yes okay
as opposed to being y'all right fine as
opposed to
yeah so an interesting question is okay
so if you said automatic in that case it
would not be the default because the
default will be list but automatic would
mean include also Association and some
other things that's right you know we
better see a list for these various
functions of what actually gets included
in automatic but I think the path were
on right now is a good start and
hopefully we can you know it will work
well I mean transpose you can mix lists
and sparse arrays and whatever so it's
automatic writes nuts
okay then automatic does not include
Association in a different way for
example numeric array if you do
transpose of a numeric array it will
transpose that but if it's buried in
list it won't it won't do it now I
believe that's correct anyway I think
it's a bug well that's part of the whole
decision is how far numeric array goes
is representing the list which is a big
can of worms it is yes it is a very
strange piece of background noise okay
well I'm not sure I think we've got a
path forward
let us try filling this out and maybe
it'll have to come back to this meeting
okay okay
sorting function so this is the question
of things like find faces how do they
sort the faces that come out or how does
text search sort the pages that come out
there although it might have a ranking
function right so and sort of you know
what the point of view that serve I've
been taking and maybe
I've been taking and I suppose it would
be good to hear Danny's point of view is
that this should be called sort by
function because it's it's you know
right we talked about ordering functions
which are the things you give to sort
and then we have perfect you give to
ordering yes so the things here the the
the argument you give to sorting
function it's not the thing you give to
sort or ordering it's the thing you give
to sort by the second argument you know
I understand it's it's the argument to
sort by it's a it's a whatever it is
it's a it's a cardinal function of
something as opposed to an ordinal of
those things called it's it's the it's a
ranking not a comparator is that the
point you're making right so that you
know calling this you know so just
basically you think sort by functions
would be you know why are we not calling
it ordering function it doesn't order
the things though it's just the function
that it's a preprocessor basically the
process up close processor it
preprocessor to the sorting part it's
exactly what the second argument of sort
by does which is a preprocessor before
sorting correct yes why wouldn't that be
called the sorting function because
we're adding another function to those
that does the comparisons and that gets
very there's an ambiguity there we're
saying it should be sort by function
right because it's clear horrible name I
mean we do we have a ranking function
for text search yet and if so what would
a ranking from a ranking function is yes
a different thing a ranking function
gives you a number or something from
which you can
ranked things right
not sure that that's really different
rate no I don't think it's really
different that's why I'm bringing it up
okay well yes except we can't call it
ranking function because that's so look
at that
look at that it was called sorting
function inside text search as well
right that's those Arak people right
once they make you say it's the Cowboys
now operating a very very stable form um
it's still a race they got a new
gardener called called Roger
and now it's really right ok so look the
reason I like sorting function is
because it's a nice sounding name I
understand your point I I don't
immediately it doesn't hit me over the
head with confusion
can we please whatever that background
noise is could we please try to mute it
Thanks
okay so I mean what are we objecting to
here the issue is that you are concerned
that sorting function sounds like the
binary comparator is that the problem
right it sounds like something you'd
give to sort rather than something you'd
give to sort by I don't buy this I'm
I I don't I mean okay I don't know maybe
I'm just I don't see that I mean I think
it's I think it's okay I think the the
description is an option that specifies
a function by which to sort the results
of a computation
yeah
I just hate the name sort by function
but read it see it says sort by function
ranked by no it's the rank by function
it's like this one is a lieutenant this
one's our general you know I don't get
it
I did it look it's the wrong part of
speech it's got a it's got a you know a
preposition sitting in the middle there
the right-hand side of that rule come on
look if somebody sees sort by function
they're going to what is that background
noise come on guys what it's not gonna
make it sort by function it's just not
something we can have you know I I
understand your objection but I think I
think it is the lesser of the evils
and sorting by function is even worse
you can't have buy in the middle
I think we should move on I think this
is this is going to be okay
I think it's you know sorry the language
the human language does not provide an
adequate solution here and I think this
is okay and let's just check what it
actually does so it's given an
association
um
and are we happy with what it actually
does here
guys sorry I was muted I think he give
it a pure function and so it does they
think they maybe have magic strings also
in certain cases or okay yeah I mean in
this case here right the fine faces five
faces returns in association by default
rate for each thing does it does it or
at least there there is a mode in which
it returns there is a case in which it
returns out I'm not sure that that's the
default return so right would have to be
documented that the sorting function is
applied to the Association
is that somebody from from the image
processing group here no there are loud
yes so okay so that's an important thing
specially you can maybe take that to
them it has to be applied to the roar
Association even if the return value
isn't the whole Association
right they claim right that that's sort
of the advantage of having it as as an
option as opposed to your own yes all
right let's move on okay random choices
does not document Association okay so
this is a complete and total mess and I
think I have some examples somewhere in
that thread and there's also a link to a
bug report so so just okay so random
choice so the issue is it's got so we
have functions like nearest I like the
machine learning functions that to
understand what it does it can either
take a let's
see it takes a weight and a value right
and I believe it takes it in that order
in a list and I believe it takes it in
the other order in an association is
that correct right that's I think it's
kind of crazy but that crazy actually I
think that's a if you look at the cases
like for machine learning this is
actually a quite good and reasonable
thing to do okay so let's look at the
case
right now random choice doesn't do that
because random choice will work with any
less right so if you give it a list of
rules it'll just pick one of the rules
right which is why it has to have this
exterior thing here let's take a look at
nearest for a second where the heck is
it documenting
where is it documenting the association
case maybe it doesn't have the
Association case
with
there we go data can also be given an
association as equivalent to value arrow
key one
right so in that case it's right-right
gives
so the nearest miss is with respect to
the first element here yep and the
return value is disease right so the
analogy in the case of random choice
would be I mean the weight is the thing
which you are randomly choosing with
respect to and that is consistent with
this case here right the WRO ease is
consistent with this case here for
nearest right yep so what that would
leave is the case we do not have for
random choice is this case here
right but we still could have the case
that goes so for example I should be
able to say something those two guys are
the same are the same rate I'm gonna
claim this this should work okay that
that should work and that would be
equivalent so in the case of nearest
alright we have we have and so random
choice so this will be equivalent to
random choice of 0.4 0.6 arrow a B
all right and the only case that random
choice does not support
is this case here 0.4 arrow a point 6 r
OB
right
well it'll
work you just won't do what you you want
it to do that's correct right so all
three of the well I think all three of
those will evaluate right now and just
the first one probably doesn't give you
what you're expecting no because we
completed the wrong thing right so that
one is wrong but other than that I think
if we fix that I think we're in good
shape
okay right but so the way why doesn't
this have a random seating option
you
well though well most of most of the
random food things actually don't have a
random seating option right like random
integer yeah I guess that's true they
could have directly accessing a random
number generator right so it doesn't
necessarily make sense there's a level
object right seating is okay in the high
level things right now before we move on
we should take a look at random sample
and make sure yes good point right so
basically and let me just explain maybe
this is obvious but right basically what
random choice was following a sort of
you know what was that one time called
the central dogma well this is a
symbolically indexed list so I'm
randomly choosing you know a value from
this list
yeah all right random sample so the
question is can random samples support
the Association case yeah I don't see
why not
seems fine right so you want the
Association case to be equivalent to the
middle guy that's correct and so it will
now return so now it will return a list
of things instead of an association so
does random choice doesn't it if you
give random choice the second argument
right I'm just saying I'm just saying
that at the present time random sample
returns a in Association so if I give
five here
no it'll give you a list yeah okay but
now if I say right because you might
have repeated elements so it can't be an
association right
and that'll because that'll get a little
good because you have too many right you
need to give it like two or nothing yeah
I think that's totally random and
useless what it's doing there
I think random samples should just treat
it the same way at random choice treats
it if you add Seger's to you know 0.3
and you drop down you know B or whatever
and you ask for two elements yeah well
that's right and I don't use phul I
claim that's not useful behavior I claim
it should do the thing treating that as
a weighted list because that's
consistent with what happens by you know
it's consistent with what happens when
lots of machine learning functions since
this is the consistency meaning and
we're discussing all of these different
represent you know short representations
of weighted information yes where does
weighted data fit into this what is
weighted data
I don't know I have no idea I mean we
should be able to give that as an
argument to random choice and what is
the relationship between weighted data
and a categorical distribution center
it needs a relation because it's the
same thing basically well I mean
basically the way the data is just the
data and I'm pretty sure you can then
construct a distribution I understand
I'm saying weighted data listen we have
this discussion coming about categorical
distributions okay which by the way
Sushma we need to get scheduled and when
we do that discussion weighted data
clearly is closely related to that and
should weighted data taken association
given notice yes it surely should I
think weighted data I don't think is
properly supported in the machine
learning functions and that's another
thing which should be addressed
the random traits and random sample work
with weighted data so I guess it's not
documented for some reason that they
certainly work they do work okay okay
well weighted data itself
I think should take an association but
probably Roger should be consulted on
that because his function originally and
meanwhile and Etienne should be Canadian
is not here is he
no I'm pretty sure the machine learning
people are at least aware of this
function how much they've integrated it
I can't say but let's check and let's
understand the relationship two
categorical distributions yeah so let's
go about here about that again and
another one of these meetings all right
let's go let's go on to the value of the
meta information option all right so we
have this option to a bunch of functions
for the can of worms all right now we
were just talking about a you know in
connection with the annotation function
we you there for the meeting about
annotations I was not okay
who was because this bat meeting is all
about this basically will you will you
there sushma took place on the 9th of
August
that's not
you
okay so this had to do with we can go
find when it was that took place on the
24th of July okay okay
so
I think the conclusion that this should
always be an association is probably
correct but I think it needs to be done
together with the Sanitation rules
business okay
you
I'm not sure that we even want to call
it metro information going forward as
opposed to annotation information
what is the general idea of this
annotation thing here where we can let's
say it's for things which are you can
see it's for strings which have like
text element and so on it's for
annotating missing data it's for
annotating you can see these different
cases cell tags masking in images etc
okay so so in other words there are
things where what you want to do is
you've got a time series you've got an
image and you want to say there are
certain annotations that I want to apply
to this clump of pixels in the image
okay and you don't want to go inside in
some cases like in some of Brett's
functions of visualization we're
perfectly happy to have a wrapper inside
the actual like a labeled wrapper inside
there but for other cases we don't want
to do that instead we want to have the
annotation be part of the wrapper the
overall wrapper and making sense to see
okay so if the question here is should
meta information always be an
association I think the answer is
probably yes but that needs to be part
of this annotation Layton you better
find out Sushma yes please put yourself
on mute whoever's please put yourself on
mute that's making that noise that the
could you find out who is that meeting
and make sure that this issue is brought
into that meeting I think the conclusion
will be that we want to make meta
information always be an association
okay all right anything else that we
have for this meeting today so no but I
can get yeah so don't exactly have all
the right people for this conversation
but I think we have enough right people
yes so if you type in I told you to be
able to start my project I build oh
they're all finally woken up okay go
ahead yep hold on oh my gosh I am so
confused by having that pulled down and
now it's got a dots which one could you
report the fact that the hundred percent
has it it's such maybe we want to tweak
that but that's because that's because
of high DPI support various things which
used to be integers are now real fine
but in that case believe me it should be
a it should be formatted as a hundred
percent that's already know okay and is
it knew that it's going just showing on
the top that's a new and I've seen that
in the version 12 builds for a while
yeah okay and I haven't yet okay in any
case byte array go ahead off one two
three yep
and then the numeric array of one two
three and you know come a byte
there's no water
by the way right so basically I mean a
better way is well putting aside the
issue of whether we should have had
something called byte array it's
essentially you know a numeric array a
one-dimensional numeric array with funny
inputs one okay fine the problem is what
so I was going to suggest that we we
make bytearray look more like numeric
array so right instead of just saying
three bytes it would say you know length
three and then you know we show like the
first five bytes or something we're not
doing that from the America right what
do you mean we're not doing that for the
microwave I don't see that for a
numerical right here I mean I see okay
so let's say range of 100 here okay okay
so we have the data in
the reason I don't think it's is useful
for byte arrays most of the time it is
just random binary gunk that has been
you know like showing the first three
bytes in a gif is not useful
mm-hmm and that's what this is usually
used for I don't think that's true I
mean as the person who's been leaving
most of the bytearray development I know
that that is not true okay what is it
right I mean we have string two byte
array we have lots of things that come
out as bytes no no I understand that but
I'm saying that I think the number one
use that people make of this is they
import something from you know they
import they pull in a file which is in
some weird binary format and they just
want to have it be in the system
mm-hmm I'm not a huge enthusiast of
showing the first bytes here we did
discuss that when we first built this I
now recall and I you know I just don't
think it's all that useful I mean if we
could say for example if we could use
our automatic identifier to say that
this is a gift for something um the UM
then okay well what about just changing
it from three bytes to length three just
to be more consistent like that I don't
think is bad okay let's let's try that
okay let's see that again okay um
someone on the livestream is suggesting
creating a neural network to find out
who is making noise and I can mute them
which leads me to a question which
probably nobody knows the answer to here
do you know if zoom has an API that we
could do that with nobody knows I
suspect no clue right um I don't think
it has a useful API I think I looked you
know several months ago for some other
reason and I don't remember what it was
but I didn't see much interesting we
wait for that to be possible um all
right anything else guys otherwise this
to wrap it up all right thanks a lot
thanks to people on the livestream
see ya